so ich habe keine ahnung was das ist
fragen lotto woher weißt du das
sensationelle sensationen ging ja fragen
leute genau das ist ja ich habe gehört
man muss die grünen nehmen glaubt nicht
dass jetzt auch alle raum sie nehmen und
nacheinander öffnen
du kannst in einer heißen muss oder will
ich mal ganz mutig und nehmen hier die
passen zu meinem shirt machst du das
eigentlich hast du das auch zu ja ich
trete das jetzt einmal abdrehen dritte
abdrängen muss abbringen abdrehen
abtreten haben sie schon viele haben
dann die fragen zerrissen muss man
letztlich wieder bei capo den boden
dafür muss man sie dann von hand
zusammen letzte halo monaco für sein
album es trafen wir dann rede für darauf
ich weiß das aber es wundert mich dass
du das weißt du ich bin vielseitig
interessiert hat ihr leben der fischer
das neue lied von ihr heißt ja
grenzenlos glaube ich was zu retten das
abkommen bisschen muss man auch die
augen offen
auch wenn man vier davon hat er kein
schlager man sich ähnlich ja ich auch
nicht aber es sehr erfolgreiche musik ja
ja auch sehr gut du wirst immer so
gelassen in deinem videos hast du
manchmal nicht einfach die schnauze voll
doch dann schaut sich die an dem ich
gerade film echt schon vor recht lasse
aber schlecht wie es dann was sind alle
zusammen was sie so nimmst du sie an den
schwächsten stellen und nähe ich
vergesse dann manchmal das
ist einfach probleme gibt also derjenige
der mich dann filmt so wenn derjenige
das dann in dem moment nicht so
hinbekommt wie ich mir das wünsche dann
bin ich da ein bisschen sauer und
schnauzen vor allem zum beispiel bei
einem videodreh gemacht mehr sein heißt
das und dann haben wir auf wir sind auf
fahrrädern gefahren weil wir halt über
waldwege und dies und das da drehen
wollten hat eine sackkarre dabei zwei
solche riesen jutesäcke mit kisten und
kugeln und sagen wir allem am fahrrad
transportiert und das geht natürlich
auch auf die energie und da kommt
irgendwo andere mit dreck gedreht
irgendwann geht ja auch die sonne unter
willst alles an einem drehtag machen
davor war diese gamescom
nachwuchsspieler des lebens verborgen
gemacht haben am nächsten tag war und am
nächsten tag war der video data es war
genau der freitag wo wir das gedreht
haben so weil ich das parallel
herausbringen wollte am sonntag da
blickpunkt am montag
und wenn dann die zeit einfach vergeht
und mich dann auch verschätzte weil du
musst ja eine ruhige hand eine kamera
wenn aber die ganze zeit irgendwas
schlepps auf dem fahrrad eine sackkarre
kannst du die kamera nicht mal anfängt
zu wackeln und dann bin ich da schon
leider manchmal auch zu
perfektionistisch sonne
aber das ist jetzt bei 10 videodrehs
einmal dann der fall so da will ich das
dann auch richtig haben und nähe aber
sonst bin ich bin insgesamt ein absolut
gelassener typ weil ich auch die sachen
selber in der hand habe die ich mache
aber eine mannschaft ist was auf die
schnauze voll deutsch ist einfach so hin
als zuvor
ich möchte für die abwechselnd ist
einfach wunderbar so abdrehen jetzt die
seite abdrehen und max aus neues make
some noise wie kommt man auf so gute
wortspiele zum eigenen namen hat sich
bei mir einfach ergeben ich heiße ja max
ist war meine mama macht und neues
museum hat sich dann irgendwann so
umgewandelt in neuss und max aus neues
was gibt's gerade das maximum neues
passt auch zur demo kelle hier weiter
ich muss noch mal das album zeigen gib
mir doch mal das album here
das ist nämlich auch der witz jetzt das
vierte album heißt endlich mach mal lärm
sowie make some noise und rhythm of
maxwell rote das macht spaß mit dem
christoph damit wirklich freue mich
immer wenn gesprächspartner offen
ehrlich und sie fallen anstrengend also
sich die gespräche aber du musst ja auch
freundin zu den gästen oder besetzt doch
jetzt nicht ich hab dann einmal mit
diesem zacher oder wie heißt der nähe
daher werde er hat doch da auch keinen
bock mehr gehabt wobei wirkt auch ein
bisschen inszeniert haben zwei es dann
eher wann die inszenierte natürlich dass
diese fragen eine andere sendung da habe
ich seine anderen frisur auch noch mit
einer furchtbaren frisur aber sind ja
heute wieder in diese zeit anderer
kannst ja das ging darum den auf die
plattform ist auf die palme zu bringen
das hat gestalten angeschafft du kannst
du aber der wahl denn war danach war der
sand ist auch sehr lustig aber bei pixum
ist die aufgabe freundlich zu den gästen
zu sein es sind ja auch gäste selbst
während der angeklagte der wobei ich hab
natürlich mein eigenes wasser mit ok das
angst dazu wäre ja wie hier habe ich
herausbekommen welche früher war das
hier alles noch anders benannt ist alles
voll wasser setzen nur was sonst muss
man nach new york fliegen du bist ja
auch hier quasi zu hause richtig aber
auf dem sofa durch die regale kommen
zurück der vollkommen hier deine
freundin hat mehr abonnenten auf youtube
als du bist du nicht eifersüchtig auf
ihren erfolg ich glaube wir reden über
niki oder ein missverständnis ist okay
sie hat auf jeden fall noch hat sich ja
mehr abonnenten als ich wisst ihr das
ding bei freunden ist so ich weiß nicht
wer diese frage gestellt hat oder wer so
denkt ist weiß auf jeden fall dass viele
leute gibt diese dinge bei einer
freundschaft ist also dass du dem
anderen das beste kunst und witziges zum
beispiel nicht single cover habe ich
fotografiert also ich hab das foto
gemacht und wird es jetzt genommen um
mein album cover hat sie gemacht und wir
unterstützen uns nach besten wissen und
gewissen und wo ich mich ein bisschen
vorne sehe ist natürlich macht
deutschsprachige musik und ich habe 82
62.000 64.000 abos die wirklich deutsche
sind und wie auch das feiern was ich
mache
sie macht cover videos auch auf englisch
zum beispiel 400 fans aus
papua-neuguinea 400 aus argentinien 400
aus brasilien und nun relativ kleine
anzahl dann aus deutschland natürlich
auch schon viele leute und die leute
erwarten von mir aber auch dieses cover
machen steigende aufmerksamkeit
klickzahlen und jetzt auch noch bei
klicks und jetzt auch noch punkte
überhaupt noch zu stoppen würde die
frage gerne umformulieren max wovor hast
du angst was dich stoppen könnte
bist du noch zu stoppen man ist ja
selbst sein größter feind
ich selber sehe noch viel potenzial nach
oben ich hoffe dass ich gesund bleibe
dass die gesundheit nicht stoppt also
bisher ist alles super aber das ist das
einzige glaube ich was mich stoppen
könnte toi toi toi dass das so bleibt
was warum soll man mich den stopp ich
tue doch keinem was sehr schön um eine
rote wobei die leute sagen einmal rot
innen und sind ganz rot
natürlich sind sie rot was wollen sie
jetzt
jetzt hatte ich sie den rosa das ist
halt eine andere form von ort will also
eine rot-rote deine songs handeln
regelmäßig vom besseren miteinander
auskommen bist du wirklich sein
weltverbesserer doch herrlich schon sagt
ja würde schon sagen weil solche was ich
ganz ab kann wenn jemand seinen kaugummi
einfach auf dem boden oder wenn jemand
irgendwo was hat so der macht irgendwas
auf und schmeißt einfach auf boni das
kann ich nicht ab oder wenn jemanden
irgendwem zu dem scheiß ist oder so das
kann ich von meinem herzen haus nicht ab
und insofern million weltverbesserer
aber ich gehe auch leider manchmal zu
mcdonald's
was gibt es noch schlimme dinge die man
machen können ich kaufe auch manchmal
klamotten in irgendeinem laden freue
mich über ein t shirt für drei euro
obwohl man sich bewusst sein muss dass
das nicht korrekt hergestellt worden
sein kann ich es jetzt längere zeit kein
fleisch auch so dass fällig ist
vielleicht auch eine art die welt ein
bisschen zu verbessern
aber ich versuche es auf jeden fall
jetzt nicht irgendwie um menschen zu
beeindrucken sondern vielleicht an er
sie zu beeindrucken zum beispiel damals
war es auch so ich habe auch zigaretten
geraucht und auf einmal wirst du dann
auf der straße erkannt du wirst ja auch
mit 10.000 abonnenten schon von leuten
erkannt vor allem wenn du immer sagt ich
bin max hamers neues dann sind neuesten
neuesten wird erkannt und wenn du dann
auf einmal siehst du wenn du dann raus
und jemand kommt an und himmelt ich
wirklich andere sagt du bist so cool ist
mein vorbild und denkt scheiße wenn ich
jetzt sieht so ein junger mensch er
sieht sich rauchen dann braucht er auch
denn der denkt dass es korrekt obwohl du
selber ja weiß es nicht korrekt ist und
das hat man bei vielen dingen geholfen
auch so dieses weltverbesserer image das
man aber ich will das ja gar nicht
aufzwingen
das ist das worauf ich pokere was ich
nach außen tragen will damit das auch
wieder zurückkommen zum beispiel du bist
jetzt ein bushido raps die ganze zeit
über ihre sozialen ließ dass die leute
auf den konzerten ich glaube er hat
selber auf seine eigenen fans keinen
bock teilweise weil die halt so aus
einer anderen milieu kommen dass er sagt
so dass es gar nicht meine welt und ich
hab dann lieber die leute ich war früher
auf pink konzerten auf herbert
grönemeyer konzerten auch zu konzerten
und hab da immer eine sehr heterogene
gruppe erlebt unterschiedliche
altersstufen zu meinen konzerten kommen
auf 50 jährige aus luxemburg extra
hergefahren und unternehmen dann den
abend und haben viel spaß
lesben schwule schwarze türken alles was
tat und das genieße ich einfach das
einfach im rila querschnitt so was spaß
macht
letzte frage
gesangstalent und ein gefühl für die
richtigen texte wie wird man zu so einem
wunderkind wunderkind also diesen
begriff möchte ich zurückweisen ja ich
hab ich hart erarbeiten ich habe als
kind hat meine schwester viel backstreet
boys gehören die dürfen sie auch mal
treffen
damals hätte es aber kein garant für ein
musikalisch gute positive entwicklung
doch mexiko
es ist so dass die lieder auch von von
britney spears wechselbar ist und so
weiter nicht ohne grund solcher hits
geworden sind das sind wenn du mal
begabte leute oder leute die ahnung
haben sind es hits einfach nur die
melodien sind bomba sind wenn heutzutage
die leute sagen max dieser refrain
bleibt mir die ganze zeit im ohr auch
beim raps sonstwo dann hat das viel
damit zu tun dass ich habe einfach gerne
früher viel gesang gehört ja als als
kind ich habe auch dann eine zeitlang im
knabenchor gesungen war ja aber ich war
dazu undiszipliniert also er war ganz
schön harte regiment das allied eu liege
die toro christi denn philips ali t
und dann war ich halt einfach das war
natürlich die stimme war noch um einiges
höher
und dann kam hat der app mit dem umzug
nach neuss und dann samy deluxe und kool
savas und absolute beginner und alles
was es gab
ob ich ein ganz cooler mixed damit
heutzutage ganz gut in die karten spielt
aber ist noch luft nach oben auf jeden
fall da entwickeln kann man sich immer
okay er hat in diesem sinne riesenspinne
bleibt dann dran
bis dann bleibt dran